عناد الشمري مو سن سعودي في محافظه رفحاء
بمنطقه الحدود الشماليه احب الابل ولازم
رعايتها منذ اكثر من سبعه عقود حتى اورث
هذا الولع لابنائه واحفاده الكاميرا
العربيه التقته عند ابله برفقه الزميل
الجزاع النماصي الذي وافانا بالتفاصيل
[موسيقى]
اعتاد الان مع نادي الشمري ندبه بين في
محافظه رفحاء في منطقه الحدود الشماليه
السعوديه منذ اكثر من سبعه عقود
امهات غاليات عندي والله ما وقفت
عيالي غالي غالي
[موسيقى]
عبده والعلياء اسمائه لهذه النقطه والشعر
التي شاركت في عده مسابقات وحصلت على
مراكز متقدمه الخامسه
عبد العزيز الله يرحمه ابو سلطان طال عمرك
واذكر ابني مبروك حفرك يا ابو سلطان اللي
بها الناس حضرو لك يا طبط الشعر بالميدان
تجمع الربع من حولك يا طبط الشيعي
بالميدان انت وين الناس
من عمره خلف ابله ورثه هذا الولع لابنائه
واحفاده
جدا
ياخذني معه
صار اكنها خبز اول نشوف انه يجنن
عناد الشمري ان يجمع احبابه في نزهه بريه
واصطحني للابل من سنار قيصومه فيحان جزاع
النماصي العربيه